hi friends this is weird
it's like a virtual keynote i'm so
nervous
uh it is one o'clock in the morning and
i'm in portland oregon
not where i want to be and i know that
you also are not where you want to be
but i appreciate that you're spending
time with us here
at uh ndc this is pretty special stuff
um hello to everyone on youtube and
on the chats and in this life and all
the places that you are
i appreciate you all spending time with
me and also for my
studio audience the speakers who have
let me stare at them
so that i don't have to talk to myself
in a strange room
while my wife is in the other room
wondering what it is that i do for a
living
this is pretty exciting stuff i really
appreciate the technology and the effort
and i want to just say thank you so much
for the team to put this together
it's really complicated to make
something as professional and classy as
this
i think it's pretty cool so thank you to
dylan and martin and all the friends
that put this together
uh my name is scott hanselman you may
know me from the internet
if you've followed me on twitter you're
probably disappointed
because you went there for technology
content and you ended up with something
else
but that's okay if you're not familiar
with me and the stuff that i do
i'll take a brief moment and just let
you know what i like to talk about
you can go to hanselman.com and you can
learn about me
or you can go and google with bing for
scott
and uh find out uh where what i'm all
about
i've been blogging for a number of years
now
in fact if you go over to my blog and
you click on
date it turns out i have been blogging
since 2002
that's 18 years of blogging which is
just
nuts in fact if you go and look at one
of my years i'll just pick
2019 for example and i'll just start
scrolling down a little bit
it turns out that i i'm kind of a
creature of habit i basically blog
every tuesday and thursday every
year for 18 years and then i've also got
a
podcast i've got a podcast called hansel
minutes
hansel minutes is called hansel minutes
because i'm an extraordinarily bad
estimator uh dylan knows this uh if you
ask me how long something will take i'll
say
about 30 minutes people will lean in
knowingly and they'll say is that
hansel minutes or actual minutes because
it's probably gonna be about three hours
uh and this show is something i'm very
proud of because i've done over
730 episodes for 14 years
every thursday so why am i showing you
this is it for the free advertising
partially
but really what it is is i realized that
i'm basically
running a little business here right
it's not a business that makes me any
money this is a business that basically
sells
ads to pay for hosting but someone made
the comment to me recently
that uh it looks like it's quite a
sophisticated
setup i've got my podcast i've got all
of my
mini sites the blog 20 years of content
there's
sites for books uh it's kind of like
hanselman incorporated
if i had uh a business and any money
and someone actually emailed me recently
and said uh can you put me in touch with
someone on your team
and i was like i felt like i was gonna
put the one phone down and pick the
other phone up and say hello
this is scott and sales let me put you
through to scott and marketing
right and now that we're all trapped
uh in our homes i was realizing that uh
i have more power than i thought not as
scott internet person or scott
programmer with a lot of twitter
followers
but as scott micro business
owner i've got this tiny little thing
here my blog my sites
about 16 different websites uh if you go
and search for
get involved in tech dot com
i've got a a two hour documentary that's
a free
movie that you can watch that i did with
rob connery that will talk to you about
how to become a social developer
that's one site uh a number of years ago
i wrote a website called
baby smash and you can actually it's not
for smashing babies it's
it's for for actual babies to play and
learn
how to like you know play with the
computer and it's super fun and these
are all websites that need
ssl certificates and they need care and
feeding
i realize that i've built a garden a
garden of things on the internet and in
fact
if you actually search for a square foot
gardening
four programmers it's very specific
square kind of square foot gardening
i've even got blogs on how to do that
i've got this garden of websites uh
there's all of the sites that i maintain
for myself and hansel and incorporated
and i say that in quotes
uh but there's also all those stupid
little one pagers you know those little
one page sites that you do just because
i made a domain because you know i was
on twitter and ian said something funny
and i
registered the domain and now it either
is a
website or it's just a failure it's just
a representation of my failure this
domain that i registered
i never did anything with one of my joke
domains is
keysleft.com where i can type in
you know how old i am and how fast i
type and it'll actually calculate
exactly how many keystrokes i have
left before i die i have 253 million
keystrokes left before i die
and this is really important because
that means i can either write 84
novels or i can write a million and a
half emails to my boss so it gives you a
sense of what you really want to do with
your time
so we're all trapped at home i've got
all these websites
there was a time there was a time when
these websites were running
on a server that i could visit and a
server that i could touch
and by touch i mean like the cloud
before the cloud you would go and
see your server some of the younger
people may not remember that but you
could go
you said where's my server and you go to
the big warehouse the big costco
winco macro kind of place and you say
where's my server oh it's on row nine
just walk down there and you go down to
the row
and you put your hand on the server
and you could push refresh on your
laptop and you'd feel the server
shutter because there was a spinning
circle of rust
that would start and grab your disk off
and would say
yep that's the server and you could say
my computer at hansman.com is on that
rack on that server and that
refrigerator in this row
in a building but with the cloud it's
not like that anymore is it you can't
visit your computer anymore
well hanselman.com has actually been
running on a server in ontario
for a very very long time and i was
running
it was the last machine that's been
running in this particular server and
that company was a hosting company that
got bought by another hosting company
that got bought by another hosting
company and recently
i was on the twitter and i searched for
from hanselman server down i think it
was
and i was having an issue where my
computer went down
and uh let me see if i can find that
website down
blah blah maybe just search for down
[Music]
it was handsome.com and it was spinning
did i make mean search for spinning rust
ah i think the spinning rust virtual
machine that has run my blog for 18
years may have died
two weeks before my migration to the
cloud this will be a live disaster
recovery thread
so then i started talking about how i
was going to move to the cloud it's a 15
year old website running.net2
right dotnet too and people would tease
me every once in a while
i would get on hacker news and some i
would say something
there was a time when i wrote an article
once called url's rui
i was telling everyone we need to care
about our uris they should be crisp and
pretty
urls or ui is not the kind of hacker
newsy thing that would go straight to
number one
and what was the first comment on hacker
news
this from a man with aspx in his
extension
how dare you even implant like you don't
even get to talk like they just they
dismissed the entire article
because i had aspx and the extension i
thought it was actually pretty good it
was because i saw this article in the
paper
with a specific a specific url for you
to click
so the computer went down and it was
very sad
and again this is a 15 year old piece of
hardware so here's the deal
i tweeted about it and then i called the
folks that run that server and i said
hey i think the computer's down can you
help me
and they said uh who are you
and i said scott hanselman i've been
i've been hosting my blog at your
website for 15 years
i'm like no no no we got bought
by some lovely french quebecers uh
who are you i had been grandfathered in
and grandfathered and grandfather and i
realized i hadn't even paid a bill
in years they'd forgotten about me and i
was actually
in a computer under like anna's desk
somewhere oh let's ask anna she was here
back in the day let's see if you're
under her desk
i was on a computer under the desk with
a post-it note on it that just said
don't
delete this it's scott's literal
physical
spinning rust when i tweeted this
that my site was down i tried to call
tech support and they didn't even
believe
that i was at their company i had to
ping and traceroute to prove that i was
hosted
and it turned out that one of the
individuals
that follows me on twitter this really
actually happened
one of the people on twitter who follows
me happened to be
in the knock the knock is like the
network station
they were actually doing maintenance on
the machine
and he went over to the machine he
jiggled the wire on the back
and he dm'd me i'm really sorry i know
this is not professional i apologize i'm
actually in the room with your server
right now
i'm going to jiggle the wire and get it
back up the server came back up and now
i'm in the process of moving this to the
cloud
okay so here on this website that says
urls are ui
i think to myself how would a company
deal with that i'm
i'm scot incorporated but i'm only one
person
one person with one server in one place
but i want to be international i want to
have global
load balancing in the cloud i want to
have cdns and all this kind of stuff and
i want my url to not have aspx in the
thing
right well if you go to a url like that
right now and then you put the word
staging in front of it
okay i hit enter
ah now now i'm ready to go
to hacker news and not well and they'll
just be mean about something else
but the point is they won't be mean
about my my url
so when you're running a little business
like this you got to think about all
these things
a 302 or 301 redirect seo
all the things that could go wrong no
robots.txt
i want to do it in a way that's scalable
and easy but i'm also going to learn
about
the internet while i'm doing it and this
has been such an exciting journey to go
and move
a 15 year old blog engine and actually
it's even older than that
it's called dos blog anyone remember
this
d-a-s blog it's german for
the blog das blog
you have to say it with like a german
and uh it was originally built by
clemens vastus with german lovely german
man you know
it's okay for me to talk like this
because hanselmann
is a german name with two ends at the
end we came to america
took away one of the ends um and
now dash blog is being converted by a
lovely man named mark downey
dos blog core
so dos blog here he goes there's papa
string so
he and i are building dos blog
in a way that will run on on
uh on linux on windows we're doing it
with uh with.net and with asp.net
and that's cool and then hansel minutes
is going to need to go over to the cloud
as well so i'm slowly slowly moving all
these things to the cloud
but then things got really complicated
i've got
my home page which is brochure where
i've got my slash blog which is
a website and i've got slash speaking
and slash pod these are all
mini sites some of them are pages some
of they're not maybe it should be i mean
think about this you're all
writing this in your heads well maybe it
should be a static site generator maybe
you should use django
you know well you could do this and you
could do that like it doesn't really
matter
as long as the urls
are clean right i could switch the whole
thing
over to urls and i say urls are
ui.aspx
i could switch the whole thing over to
static site generators or github pages
but i i don't want to lose my legacy i
don't want to lose this
every link matters right every link
matters
so i started learning about ways to go
and do this so i thought i would spend a
little time showing you how i've been
doing this development and what makes me
happy and how i feel like
i'm just a whole company
but i'm just one person like i don't
have a build person or a security person
or cloud person it's just me
and i only have 67 in credit in azure
that's another good thing if you ever
meet somebody from microsoft who tells
you all about the cloud and everything
and then you find out that they've never
actually paid for anything before they
only do it in free credits
don't trust them always pay for always
pay for your own stuff
so this is the hansel minutes dashboard
the first step in becoming a an official
real
company and feeling like you're
important even though you're just one
person in a room in portland oregon
is you get a cool dashboard and if
you're really fancy you buy a television
set
a really cheap one and you put it up on
the wall
and you put the dashboard on the wall
and ideally if there's a map of the
earth with
dots that show all the different
countries that you're in it's even more
impressive
i like to say that i have a global
office space you know starbucks any any
country in the world
i put together this really cool
dashboard to give me an idea
of how much money i'm spending and i'm
really really cheap
like i don't want to spend a lot of
money you know
20 bucks here 30 bucks there anything i
can do to make this thing
work so while you might say hey scott go
to a site
a static site generator in fact what we
end up doing
is we uh just cache everything 20 years
of blog
stored entirely in memory makes it
really fast and it's never been
knocked over for traffic and this is a
an example let's see if i scroll
how fast our friends at webex can
capture
all the different stuff we've been doing
so it's a lot of content a lot of great
content
going over many years okay so
what i did is i started with a thing
that i just learned about called
front door azure front door it's kind of
like cloud flare
super cool so what this lets me do
is design
my front end i've got my staging in my
handsman.com so i've got production and
staging
all right and then i've got back end
pools remember how i said the main site
is different from the blog one
and then i put in rules
here i'm learning about whether or not i
want to force https or have blogs with
slashes
here are the two main routing rules here
and then when you have
this one here that's blog they take care
of paying for the https
i can go and put in patterns and it's
basically
lying to my app and doing the automatic
rewriting and what's called
x dash forwarded headers get
automatically passed in
and the real blog is over here go to
blog
and we'll say hansel and blog look oh
see this one here remember i told you i
have a lot of
websites this one here is an extremely
important website
that is uh my son's website he made it
in
visual studio code and
uh there's very important details about
about reuben the hamster
and also we've got i think we had a
copyright issue with uh
with the youtube video anyway that's
also very important is running in a
container in the cloud
okay uh app service here we go
so sometimes you go here we go this is
uh here here's hanselman blog you can
see the traffic and the data out moving
around
um when people go and learn about azure
one of the first things that they do is
they say i want to make a website in
azure and they go make a new website
and then it's like 50 bucks oh microsoft
with a dollar sign
you suck and then they just delete it
and they go off and get a dyno
i don't know heroku or whatever right
well it turns out that azure
and people at microsoft are really bad
at naming stuff
because when you make a website in azure
it's called an app service
not a website that would make too much
sense and when you make a vm
where you can put websites that's called
an app service plan
not a vm it's actually a vm
i am notoriously cheap as we have all
said
i'm not only i am german but i'm also
half scottish
and scots are well known for being
incredibly cheap
you'll never catch uh corona from a scot
because the scott never gives anything
away
um and here
[Laughter]
here i've got
two app services i've got one on windows
and one on linux let's
let us zoom in just to prove it
that's the proof that that's running on
linux i'm just going to put
as many arrows as i can around it okay
now look look at this
i've got 14 applications running
in my main server farm and i got four
in the other it's surprising to me when
people start thinking about the cloud
they start thinking about it the way
they think about virtual machines
oh you know this computer we've got this
virtual machine it's got like 40
utilization 60 utilization we need to
start thinking about capacity planning
when you think about capacity planning
we should have more
space to grow but when the cloud it
doesn't work that way you should work
that machine into the ground
you should make it work hard what do i
have a lot of
on this machine i've got a ton of cpu
this thing's not even trying it's not
even breathing
you could beat on this and it would
never hit 10 percent because i cache
everything
look at this i'm barely hitting 40
memory
16 different sites full it's just loaded
up with memory
because when you go in here and you look
at these app service plans which are
really just virtual machines
what you got to do is ask yourself what
do i need and how much do i want to
spend
i'm spending more money here i'm
spending double what i used to i used to
buy a two gig one
i don't care about the perf i wanted the
four gigs of ram
that's the deal i'm loading these things
up
i've got like 16 18 websites running on
two machines
and i could probably probably shove them
onto just one machine and in fact that
is going to be my entire goal
my goal is to get all these 14 machines
all these 14 apps here on windows
over to linux because it's 20 or 30
cheaper right i'm going to have more
perf i'm going to have a faster thing
notice that i'm actually getting the
premium ssds
for the same price windows cost me on
standard so i'm slowly making my tiny
companies maneuver
over to linux here but remember back to
dos blog
dos blog runs only on
windows right because it's dotnet 2. so
we slowly started
moving it we started moving it i started
moving it and i started moving my
uh my podcast so let's go out here to
github and let's look at hanselman first
here's hanselman.com
and let's look at hansel minutes here's
the code real actual code
okay this oh i'm using by the way i'm
using windows
terminal which is just yummy i love it
i cannot say enough nice things about it
you should get it
and you should have really cool prompts
and stuff as well because
it's the best okay so here's hansel
minutes um notice this here i've got
these
docker build docker run what's going on
there
let's go take a look at that let's look
at uh
type docker build
what is going on there
you know what that's called everyone
this is a linux system that people just
take for granted that's a shebang
that hash bang there at the front called
a shebang tells us
that that power shelf that powershell
extension windows does everything based
on extensions
but linux would much rather be told
explicitly what to do in the first line
of the text file
that's ignored because it's a comment on
windows but it's used on linux which
means that i've actually got
a powershell build file that works on
both linux or windows which is super
interesting and useful and it'll come up
in a second so then i can go and say
docker build
i'm on windows right now on the d drive
and it says hey
talk into docker right that's cool so
it's going to go and it's going to build
my
little application it's doing the build
on
docker and what i'm in fact doing
i'll open up another tab so i've got my
build
over here okay and i'll come out here
and i'm going to say wsl dash dash list
dash v and you can see i've actually got
a number of linuxes running in wsl too
one of them is in fact
docker itself so i'm on windows using
the docker desktop
talking to the docker that's running
within the context of wsl if i say
windows docker images
i see my docker images from windows
but if i go out to let's let's
close some of these and let's open
up here look at all my lovely choices
let's pick ubuntu
and let's go and say hey ubuntu
and let's say docker images and then
i've got my docker images we are
sharing the exact same docker context
so whether i built it in windows or
built it in
uh in from wherever whether i kick off
the docker building windows or linux it
doesn't matter so there you go i just
built that
okay so there i built my lovely uh
multi-layered docker thing and i can go
and run that
i now can do something else that i've
really been enjoying lately
what if i did
docker test i could actually go and run
a build
and then this is a horrible thing but
this is the kind of horrible thing you
do when you're a one-person shop
if is windows right because it all comes
down to a horrible switch statement
where you make a judgment call if it's
windows do this
otherwise it's that this is where we get
into the whole argument about
slashes versus backslashes this is a
longer conversation
that we won't be having this morning but
i want to point out though that
dockertest.ps1 works everywhere
the other thing you might say is why
would you use powershell power nobody
uses powershell
i'm not using powershell here this is
bash right i'm over here
in uh in ubuntu i don't care about
powershell from a shell
perspective i care about it from an
automation perspective
that's power i didn't tell anyone
where's powershell oh it's off somewhere
else it's often
in whatever i didn't put in the path i'm
using powershell as a
as a script runner more than i am for a
uh a uh a shell
okay now let's go and run
test instead and let's do some tests and
see if they run i haven't tested this in
a while maybe this is not even gonna
build let's find out
we'll do a test not on docker but rather
we'll do one
on the metal and see how much trouble we
get into here
and let's see what's going on test run
it's thinking i hear fans
turning on things are freaking out
um pause for effect
something's going to happen what's going
on
the disc is happening see the circle of
patience
is this the demo that's going to fail
this is not really a demo it's my actual
website which would be even more tragic
because if it was one thing it's one
thing to fail at demo is another thing
to actually not be able to build your
website
at any moment oop hang on
hang on what's what's that webex
you're covering up the demo working on
another screen
scandalous so what's happening is
the test runner has spun up selenium
wait on another screen what it's been
working all the time
it's actually loading up a local version
of my
podcast look it says look look look look
look at that look what what what
yes yes i love it i love it
chrome is being controlled by automated
test software we are
currently watching selenium hanselman
has test coverage
good night everybody that was the show
here i'm actually using coverlet which
is a lovely.net based
test coverage application and i went and
i passed all of my tests
who says hanselman doesn't test 23 tests
ship it straight to production that's
certainly enough tests to go directly
into production right
it's still it's a decent amount of tests
it's pretty good i'm pretty proud of
myself
some of those tests are selenium tests
and some of those tests are functional
tests and some of them are integration
tests
there's different layers in the testing
onion as our friends at mdc conferences
well know so how are we doing this
right what's going on let us open this
in visual studio code
shall we visual studio code is loading
[Music]
okay i've got two applications
one is tests i made one called selenium
tests
again behind every great
function is a hack that you've buried in
a static
uh this is called in docker or build
server
in the class are we are we
because we ask ourselves are we dot in
docker or build server
and then we go and we look at a couple
of things first thing i look at is
agent name which tells me whether or not
i'm running in the context of azure
devops
and did you know that net say mean
things that you might about the.net team
they actually make an environment
variable called.net running in a
container
when they're running in a container and
that's how you know makes it really
really easy
so then i start up selenium as part of
the test
which i'm very proud of and then
[Music]
i make a a trait in x unit that's called
skip when live unit testing so visual
studio's background testing
isn't popping chrome windows up
frantically
and then i love this line line 100 it's
always line 100. look at that look at
that
look at them look at them look at them
are we
in docker or build server get out of
there
so that means if we run that exact same
test
in docker which
would not be able to then pop up a real
version of chrome chroma we need a
headless version of chrome or phantomjs
or
any number of different uh little things
hellos look see steven's uh
boss has just shown up to uh to watch
the session i appreciate that
i love having an audience docker test is
going to go and run the exact same
stuff by the way i love these i don't
know about you but
3d accelerated ray tracing fine
impress me with an ascii progress bar
i'm that guy
i love a nice ascii progress bar don't
you
you know what i'm talking about michael
you feel it it's good look at that
you just like if you put an ascii
progress bar in your application it
means that you care
it means that you you care and that you
want people to feel good about the
experience at the command line
i want more i'm a slash verbose person
i want to talk i want slash slash slash
v not slash q
we don't need any of that you want to
know
you want to know a funny thing about
those little command line things you get
there is that really hard
that is no it's that is why you need a
carriage return without a new light
because if you print a carriage return
it takes at the beginning of the line
you got and you can draw another one
without
putting it below it that's why we need
it that's so that's when it will always
this is why i like you dylan because you
add value and here's the thing my friend
that's a perfect segue as i build as i
do my tests
to my youtube channel with my new
exciting playlist called
pause for effect called computer stuff
they didn't teach you in school my first
episode what's a carriage
and who's feeding it lines
i would encourage you to check out if
you would like to know what a carriage
is if you are under the age of 50
and you want to know who's a carriage
what's a carriage what's happening
i talk about typewriters because when
you have a
get issue when you've messed up an
entire
repository with white space and it's all
your fault
it turns out it's because they needed a
code
to tell the carriage to return and feed
the lines
it's just tragic tragic stuff all right
ooh look
look friends what's happening here
why did i skip four tests
because i don't have a chrome in the
docker container and i'm too lazy to
hook up a headless chrome
to do the work inside of there with no
ui but i'm learning and i'm having a
good time with it
what's cool about this is i've proven
that i can run this in docker i can run
on windows
i can run it with and without heads
everywhere
it runs it works next step
let's make it automatic so let's go to
handsome end.vision.com and
that the best part of this whole thing
and all the learning that i'm doing is
remembering
that uh i'm just one person but when you
have great unit tests and you can go get
clone and build
you feel like at least three people you
know what i mean
so if we go to uh here we go here's my
this is my azure devops
uh and i've got my blog my website my
podcast and my blood sugar system
you can learn about my artificial
pancreas if you want to go and google
for
hanselmann diabetes you learn all about
that uh go to hansel minutes
and we can go and see all the fun stuff
that we're doing
let's look at our pipelines look at that
i've not only got unit tests but i've
got a lovely ci cd
and this is the best part look at this
auto i don't know how to do the arrows
anymore pr automated
this is how you make one person feel
like multiple people let's go to my
my secret github
to my fantastic private not for you
people
not this is totally i'm not giving you
my reason it's private is not because
the code is interesting it's because
you're all going to steal the css
and i paid someone for that and i don't
want you to take it um
look at this this is when you imagine
this my friends
you are social distancing you wake up in
the morning on a private repository and
you have 11 pull requests
and you say to yourself self
why do i have 11 pull requests i was
asleep who
is doing these pull requests ah
depend about have you used depend about
dylan have you experienced the joy and
the wonder that is depend bought
not voluntarily it just popped up one
day it's
so cool it's a person that's not a
person
that looks at your libraries and sees
that they changed
updates them for you makes the best prs
and when i say best prs i'm talking
about
chef's kiss prs you know what i'm saying
let's look at what a gorgeous uh uh pr
i love that i've been talking i want to
pause for a second and look at a
question that just came up on youtube
because this is important
uh individual just said the most
impressive thing
so far is the ability to make custom
arrows on the screen
i just want to say that i have i have
moved a 15 year old blogging engine
from.net 2 into linux
into the cloud scaled it globally put
together a ci cd
i've got dependable putting in prs for
me i've got it running on wsl
on windows on linux and you're impressed
with the arrows and i appreciate you
because those are actually being those
are actually coming from
from zumit uh jose quieros these come
from
zumit from our friends at uh zumit
from uh mr racinovich so check out zoom
it that is how i'm drawing on the screen
but i'm i'm glad that you are
unimpressed with this the global
elastic scale of the cloud and rather
impressed with my arrows
um okay check this out look at this
depend a bot okay dependable made a
comment two
days ago uh you should bump this from
this version
this is the best look at this here you
open it up
they actually go and dig out the release
notes link to them and copy paste them
in
then they actually
figure out the commits on the previous
version to your version inclusive
and then list out the commit so you can
tell what they changed and whether or
not you should upgrade
so freaking cool then then
you can talk to it okay look at this
see what it says oops dependabot where'd
it go
commands check this out you one
individual
who has no employees can then go hey
depend about go ahead and rebase that
or oh you know close this pr reopen this
pr or ignore this
talk to me when it's a major version the
power that we as individual humans have
now even in these difficult times when
we are stuck in our homes
uh in my little tiny mini business here
the power of automation is just so
unreal
i just love that someone a bot is doing
this for me
i love that i can check in code and it
will build in the cloud and deploy to
the cloud into staging
the idea that i even have a staging site
is so far from the way that i used to
edit stuff directly in ftp
in production and then just hit refresh
and hope that the site didn't fall over
the power of automation is such a joy uh
for us
right now that i want to kind of like
remind you that it's a thing
remind you whether it be things like
containers or
the cloud or open source what a joy what
a wonderful joy
let me also show you one other fun thing
uh that's not directly related to
hanselman.com
but it's so awesome that it has to be
talked about um
let's go out here so i'm on wsl we
talked about this the windows subsystem
for linux you can prove it by running
if it makes you happy you can see that
there's in fact processes over here that
are
talking to doc or desktop and if i go
in here and let's see do i have any
anything in this folder
uh i don't do i have.net
in this thing.net version i do have a
version of.net
let's go and make a dylan uh is nice
and we'll say dylan is nice okay it's an
empty folder
new uh web
okay so i'm gonna go file new project
command line edition
that's what that is and now i've got
stuff
now where am i i am in
linux okay i'm going to say code
dot to be clear this is linux
i will then
oops what am i doing click the wrong oop
that's the wrong button
okay then i will go code dot and i will
run visual studio code
from linux
this is stub now watch watch watch
visual studio code knows it was launched
from ubuntu
but it's in windows if i
go file open
what file system is that
that's the linux file system
here if i say show local
this is the windows file system
what visual studio code has done
is it has run a server if we run
back over here and we run h-top
let's see where our server is
see if i can get it to do something
maybe i can get this to build
and in the output of this it was running
there it is
a remote server it runs it splits visual
studio in half
has visual studio windows visual studio
server
and why is that interesting let's close
out of here let's go back to windows
what if we go over to something like do
i have go
okay check this out this is windows i do
not have
go on this computer i'm on windows i do
not have go i'm not a go programmer
code dot opens up visual studio code
it says this is a developer container
why don't you do this in a container
sure
let's do that let's move that guy reopen
in container
look at the lower left corner says
opening remote starting dev container
we are now in a container
and if i go here and i say i o dot
i have full go because i'm running in
the context
of the container
that makes sense so now i can hand
this folder to ian right
or to jessica and say here and then it's
open it
and all the tool sets that they need are
there because if you look at the dev
container
the json has two things
first the docker file with the tool kit
that it needs
and this is the cool part what's this
these are extensions visual studio
code extensions but where are they
installed i don't want to clutter my
machine my machine's lovely i don't want
to mess it up
so what we do is we separate
the local extensions
go is only installed in the container
not cool so that auto installs the
extensions you want in the context of
the container
and remotes them so any extension in
visual studio can live both locally
or not those servers are actually
running
in the context of this
container right here see
those are the nodes processes that are
talking to visual studio code
and then there's some ghost stuff
really great stuff so then extrapolate
extrapolate to what kind of damage you
could do if you
went to something like this
actually let me not log in with work
i'll show you what i'm paying for
because i don't want to be the guy
that does demonstrations and doesn't pay
for it
where is my other browser there we go
let's pull this one over here online
dot oops online.visualstudio.com
sign in
and while i'm doing that i do want to
call something out though this is
interesting a gentleman said
that's a simple lift and shift it's
actually not there's more than
there's more there than a lift and shift
i'll talk about that in a second but i
want to point out here
i've actually put a development
environment let's say that i don't have
a big machine a big beefy computer
i can instantiate one in the cloud
but i'm not going to remote desktop into
it that would be coarse that would be
like oh yeah you made a virtual machine
a remote it into it
right instead what if i could actually
open that
turn this on boot that up and then do
the exact remoting trick that i just
showed you
and let all the compilation happen in
the cloud
so you could be on a chromebook or a 300
walmart laptop and make a machine that's
you know per second building in the
building in the cloud
connect to it
oh i don't have visual studio code or
have installed
which one do i have there's insiders and
there's
visual studio code let's try that again
so when you connect to it you have like
your plan you can figure out like what
plans you want
so over here i can say i want to go and
make a new plan
that's going to be this big it'll be a
linux machine that's super powerful yada
yada
we'll spin this up in a second here and
a plan there is a vm right
and this is the thing right i mean it's
they're just so bad at naming it's just
unreal
i don't know why that's not letting me
connect i may have changed my
what i want let's see if we can go from
over here so when i go back over here
and i want to say
connect is it remote
there's all these remote things that you
can do
there it is remote containers close
remote connection
this is all just an extension of visual
studio code which is lovely remote
containers visual studio online
i think i didn't even install a visual
studio online
vs online extension
here it goes visual studio online blah
blah blah
did i sign in i think so
i think i i wonder if i'm blocking it at
the pie hole
i have a um a pie hole
which is a we got a comment come through
on youtube saying click on link not on
connect
so you might you might want to try this
click on the link click on link not on
connect apparently
well i clicked on the link try both
try both this one will go into the
environment this way which is visual
studio code in the browser
thank you for that dolly appreciate your
help let's go and do that while i'm
doing that
this is again all in preview so this
thing changes every couple of days
because
they're releasing new versions all the
time it's
that right there where this should
actually be
vs code colon slash slash
it's actually a protocol handler
so that right there is one of my
extensions
that's mad at me or
it's an edgium thing
this is the whole url's a user interface
and if the protocol in the url
doesn't work then hey the user interface
just failed right
i'll figure out why that's not working
but when you late
when i do the click on the link there i
am in here what i would have done of
course
is jumped over into visual studio code
like we just saw
and it would have connected remotely and
in this case here this is in fact dos
block now let me get back to the point
there where christian was saying it's a
simple lift and shift
yes it would be incredibly naive to
simply
pick up a virtual machine that was
sitting on a thing and then stick it
into the cloud
that would be lame why would i do that
so let's talk about
legacy code very briefly because i'm
running out of time
uh legacy code is a funny thing my
friends uh when you've got something
that's super
old but it totally works uh you tend to
not want to break it
and my blog is one of those things so
where is the database for uh the
hanselman
blogging system for the last 20 years
you may ask
well it's in here
pause for effect
i love that some of you are muted and i
can see you laughing which is lovely
um yeah so it's basically 5000 xml files
in a folder
right because that's how you roll when
it's 2001 and xml is the new hotness
you laugh now but i know you have json
files in a folder
and you think that your curly braces are
so much better than my angle brackets so
boo
boo hoo okay now lift and shift
to the gentleman's point on the chat
would actually be yeah pick up a virtual
machine and put it into the cloud yay
good job
uh kudos to you but how could i move
my stuff into the cloud potentially in a
more sophisticated manner
setting me up for future success well
putting it in a virtual machine would be
kind of eh fine
putting it in a port in a docker
container would make no sense
why because the data needs to be outside
the docker container i want to do a
mapping right well what we do what we
did is we moved our application from
running from running on windows on iis
to running in linux on kestrel which
means it can then run in a docker
container
i deploy it into i commit it into github
it goes over and gets built into
um visual studio um excuse me azure
devops rather
and then we go to the blog here
it's actually handled my blog
look at this configuration
path mappings we lie
to our old application and we
said this folder here
points to an infinite azure files
share what that means is
i can go into the azure storage explorer
and map the azure storage this infinite
disk in the cloud
and copy all of those files over there
which is super interesting right
that means that all the data is
completely externalized from the
application but i didn't have to
tell the app that i didn't have to teach
the app that i literally
lied i want to point out also to our
friend who may have shown up a little
bit
late there uh mala in gasar digital
unless you have azure free pass from
being an azure employee a microsoft
employee
this is not an azure free pass this is
my actual personal
azure and i pay for it with my own money
and it comes out of my credit card and
i'm happy to show you the bill i don't
get free
azure money but i appreciate you
bringing that up because i've actually
done a series of blog posts if you go
and search for hanselman
penny pinching in the cloud
did a series of blog posts about how
cheap i am
and how i can save money in the cloud so
definitely not
doing that for for free cool
um so then look at this
blog content this is azure storage
explorer
see where it says four thousand five
thousand cast items
all the xml lives there that means it's
redundant remember at the very beginning
of the conversation i talked about how
you used to be able to visit your disks
i can't anymore my blog doesn't know
that it's moved
from net on windows and iis to
net core open source in a docker
container in a linux machine in the
cloud somewhere
that moves around and the xml files that
it calls
file.open on they don't even exist
anywhere near it they're on an azure
share somewhere
so through a series of lies we call them
abstractions
in the software world as we lie to this
system
we actually go from being a simple lift
and shift to being a really
creative way to move a legacy
application in the cloud
the next really interesting bit as we
get towards the end of the conversation
is the images where do all the images go
well not only are there 5000 plus xml
files there's actually
thousands more images inside of that
blog content folder
and those images right now
have only a couple of
uh they're hard-coded basically like
it's hanselman.com
blog slash images yadda yadda and
there's gigabytes and gigabytes of these
images
how do i put them on a cdn this is where
it get
it all goes to heck this is where if
you've been offended already you will be
you know you're like this guy can't code
uh and at all this guy sucks
let me show you how bad i can suck and
you may
let let he and she who has never worked
in a legacy system
uh cast the first stone let me just tell
you that
until you've worked on a machine that is
older than you
uh let me just say uh be empathetic be
gentle be kind
um if i show you the
i want to say it is
almost done it's going to be it's going
to be crazy code
opening code test test
it is in a file called jinyang
log item all right
dylan drink this in tell me what's
happening on line 31
and why it's both genius and horrible
uh
that's string replacement
yes it's all because it always is string
replacement there's two ways to solve
this problem
go into the database write a regex and
steal every single reference to
this url in five thousand files
and replace it to a new one that's one
when you say database there you're
talking about a huge folder full of xml
that's 15 years old right database in
airports
right your other option would uh would
also mean uh
i could go in in a rewriting module so i
could
capture every single moment where the
browser
asked for that url but then i cost it
would cost a 301 redirect
so i need to catch it on the way out not
the way
in like it would be interesting to grab
it on the way in
but what i want is to do is i want to
catch on the way out so again i drop
every single thing into azure storage
okay
and then i make a cdn
the hansel cdn and what hansel cdn does
is amazing pat myself in the back
because look
i just make these subdomains and i go
and say where's the origin
where's the origin for these things you
know it's just this cdn
so instantly what happens is the entire
blogs every image on the blog
gets replaced and sent off to the cdn
the whole site gets faster
because the blog images are now stored
in
portugal and not in oregon everybody
wins
and then one day and then here's the
best part you put in to do
really need to fix this uh but but not
me
someone else you know someone who's not
me but i will get around to eventually
going and replacing that
okay and i think that's all my time but
i wanted to just talk about how
lovely it is to be a a one-person shop
and get all of this stuff working um i
remember
20 years ago getting cruisecontrol.net
just started and we were just doing
extreme programming and
and uh end unit testing on.net and
i just love that everyone has a every
language.net
ruby python everyone's got a great unit
testing framework everyone can enjoy
get everyone can enjoy unit testing uh
and i appreciate uh
christian and our our friends who are
playing sarcasm with me here on the chat
um i i appreciate you giving me talking
points
and i appreciate you also uh letting me
tease you gently
knowing that it is all with a sense of
love and uh and in community
so scott we do we have two quick
questions
both of them are about your windows
terminal setup oh my goodness
so one of them is is actually it's a
question from me so on your the little
orange bit of your prompt there
what are the glyphs mean the the plus
nine squiggly two minus one bang
so this means that there are nine
uh things that have been added to get
staging
too modified and one removed in my dirty
git repository here oh that's cool so
that's just like a sort of ambien
this is this is how much changes you've
got and how much stuff is outstanding
and hasn't been limited
what's going on here though what's the
what's the down four then
there's four changes above me ah
okay so i'll pull them down
neat and now there's the four changes
see down four now there's four changes
now here i have one locally hit status
there it is nice
cool the other question uh danny the
clerk asked this one throughout our
slack channel
was um the some talks you did last year
you talked about having
like diabetes and blood sugar readouts
coming up in your terminal when you're
working is that still a thing you're
doing
yeah yeah so if you go to hansel and
diabetes git
uh we have a on some of my other prompts
i have my blood sugar happening in my
prompt in real time
and that's updated with a local service
that calls a rest endpoint
updates a local text file and then the
prompt picks up that text file
but i know my blood sugar is on my watch
now it's on my wall
i don't need to put it in there and i
can also view it
um you know on i can actually go and
view it
like on a website and look at it too so
i'm good either way
oh another thing i wanted to point out
also is that these websites that i play
with
i actually have the exact git commit and
build
and link to them at the bottom of the
website so i can go and see
that was the commit and that was the
build so anytime i'm like well what is
the production running
it's running that pull request and it
built from that pipeline
and all of that's on my blog
fantastic so the one thing we've not
worked out how to virtualize yet is
rounds of applause
uh but i'm sure that that everybody
around the world the 300 and how many we
got 381 people watching this on youtube
so thank you all of you for tuning in uh
thanks to we've got a little kind of
time audience of people in the call here
because it's much easier than talking to
a webcam by yourself but
what is it two o'clock in the morning
where you are scott it is now 202 am my
friends
so on my ninth diet coke of the day
um on behalf of all of the attendees uh
the speakers partners everyone has put
this together thank you so much for
joining us and doing that
uh we will we will all be hanging out
online uh the folks who are attending if
you've got a ticket to nbc porto
see us in the slack workspace there's
going to be chat and stuff happening on
there
uh to all the folks who are watching on
youtube you should have bought a ticket
but hey we got this thing coming up in
oslo next month so still time to get in
for that
um thank you very much scott we're going
to take a short break
i think i'm doing a talk in 20 minutes
so i need to go and find a web
one of those webcam things uh i wonder
if do you think amazon can ship one of
those to me in 15 minutes
it can't be that hard right
thank you everybody for joining that
thank you scott have a great day and a
great conference everybody we will see
all of you
online take it easy